[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spring and albert breer
senior nfl reporter and of course lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback where do you think
we stand with the jets there albert
i think they're still open to moving
darnold i think if somebody had given
them their price
they may they may have moved him already
and i think that price is probably
around a second-round pick and something
else
uh maybe in between like what um the the
niners got for alex smith all those
years ago which was two
twos and what the cardinals got for josh
rosen
um in 2019 which is a two and a five
um so you know i think they're still you
know very open to
to listening to offers eight teams have
called them
on sam darnold so there has been some
level of interest
um you know and i think for the the new
gm um
joe douglas who's been there for a
couple years now actually the new coach
uh robert sala
really the ideal for them was to be able
to see the quarterbacks throw live
and get all of their medicals before
moving darnold or making a final
decision to move darnold
and zach wilson throws tomorrow justin
fields throws next week
so by the time we get to the middle of
next week the jets are going to have
seen everyone throw live
and i think they're going to have a
better idea of what they're looking at
with the byu quarterback with the ohio
state quarterback back they've obviously
already seen
lands throw so i still think the
likelihood is they take zach wilson and
find a way to move sam darnold
um but they've been trying to i think
like kind of
i guess maintain some level of
flexibility here
until they actually get to see these
guys throw and it's important to
remember dan too
it's a very different year scouts really
weren't on the road in the fall there
was no combine
so you know joe douglas physically has
not
been eye to eye with zach wilson or
justin fields
yet and making a final decision on one
of those guys
without actually being able to size them
up um you know with your own eyes
to tie your job security to that guy
which is what you're doing if you take a
quarterback second overall
it's a scary thing to do so these are an
important couple days ahead for the jets
but also leverage wise that you don't
want to chip your hand if you're the
jets that you
still want to have that mystery of are
we keeping darnold
uh do you want that number two pick if
you trade darnold then
everybody knows what you're doing with
the number two pick right and i i think
they
i mean they still really like darnold
you know like that's the thing about it
they really do like sam
um you know i think they just feel like
at this point
they either have to go all in on him or
cut the cord
um and really that's logistically where
they are in the contract you know after
three years
you know the way these contracts work
with uh with first round picks
that's where the decision point comes
that's when you have to make a decision
on the fifth year option
these guys become eligible for long-term
deals at the same time
so you know you're sending a signal what
you think of the guy
after year three because you have to
make the decision on the fifth year
option you have to make a decision on
whether or not to extend them
and so that's sort of why i think they
are where they are with sam would they
like to
see him for a couple more years sure you
know like if they had them at a good
rate that'd be fine
the fact is they're going to they'd have
to pay them almost 20 million dollars to
keep them in 2022
which makes that decision i i think a
little more difficult but you know to
your point
you know maintaining you know the the
mystery till draft day
i might be the smart move it's what the
cardinals did right
cardinals wouldn't i wouldn't tip their
hand to anybody now i think some of us
knew
that kylo murray was probably going to
be the pick for a couple weeks leading
up to that draft but they held on to
josh rosen all the way up until draft
day and didn't move him
actually until the day after they took
kylo murray
i was also told by source the safest
pick in the draft aside from trevor
lawrence
you want to guess besides trevor
lawrence
yes kyle pitts
patrick certain okay yeah okay yeah
said that that's interesting i like
certain's interesting in that
he's got nfl bloodlines he's like his
tape is
like very very clean what they say about
certain is that maybe he doesn't have
the ceiling
that virginia tech's caleb farley or
south carolina's jc horn have
like he's not quite the freak athlete
that those guys are
but i think i mean i think whoever told
you that
dan i 100 see what they're saying
because
um you know he's sort of i mean just i
mean
i i i can't imagine you find too many
nfl people that would look at him
and not think this guy's a 10-year
starter in the league now will he become
darrell rivas
you know maybe horn or farley have a
better chance of being that sort of
player
but i don't think there's any question
that there's a consensus that certainly
is going to step into the nfl and be a
really solid player
all right explain to me what's going on
with green bay because it feels like
it's either something good for aaron
rodgers or it's something bad for aaron
rodgers
yeah well i think all the talk of the um
you know the of the renegotiation and i
think
one thing we all have to remember here
when when players restructure their
contracts they're really not giving up
anything right um
they're basically moving money around
and sometimes they're getting the cash
in their pocket faster
which can help the team from a cap
standpoint that's all that's really
happening
in most of these cases there are cases
where there are pay cuts this isn't
going to be one of those
and there are in a lot of cases um you
know triggers in the
in the player's contract where they can
do these things automatically
i think that the packers if they're
going to restructure aaron rodgers
they're going to go to him first
and to me like this would seem to be
like an elegant solution
right like if you go to aaron rodgers
and you say okay
like we're going to continue building
the team that we've built and we're
going to can we're not going to
veer off of the way that we've tried to
put this whole thing together but
we're going to work with you so we're
going to restructure you we're going to
get some money in your pocket a little
bit earlier
than than you would have gotten it
otherwise and we're going to use the cap
savings to go add player x player y or
player z
to me like that that would be a very
elegant way of
addressing the concern that aaron
rodgers has
that the packers aren't working with
enough urgency working with say the
urgency the chiefs have what patrick
mahomes or
the buccaneers have with tom brady and
saying like okay like we've got x amount
of cap space
we're going to work with you to try and
improve the team
but we're still not going to veer off of
what our principles have been in putting
this whole thing together but i at some
point
what are the packers doing with jordan
love because the the benefit is the
rookie contract
but we don't know if he can play and at
some point
don't either you admit you made a
mistake or
you you say to aaron rodgers after next
year aaron thank you
but now we got it i mean this is the
reason why you moved up in the draft to
get him
in the first place i think the
comparison
that you want to look at here like
everybody out there listening wants to
look at
was the patriots drafting jimmy
garoppolo
in 2014 when the patriots took jimmy
garoppolo
tom brady was getting older he wasn't
pleased with his contract situation
and like i think the patriots knew that
was going to go up tom brady's tailpipe
at that point one of two things was
going to happen right okay
either a tom brady was going to be
reinvigorated and challenged and
play at the top of his game or b brady
was going to age
and they were going to have a guy in
place to replace him i think the exact
same thing applies here i think the
logic for the packers
and taking jordan love last year was
identical
you you bring them in right and you hope
that maybe where the relationship's
gotten a little strained now you get a
super motivated player what happened he
was the mvp of the league
right and so like you get this super
motivated player
and going forward now you also have the
potential successor
on the roster and so if he falls off at
all over the next two or three years
well then you know you've got a tough
decision to make but at least
you're not in the wilderness looking for
a quarter net quarterback you've got an
answer there on the roster
and like what's the worst case scenario
the worst case scenario i
like i don't even want to call this the
worst case scenario i mean in brady's
case what happened
brady keep kept beating garoppolo out i
mean
belichick started to build a team for
like the brandon cooks trade
when they trade for brandon cooks that
was for jimmy garoppolo
that was a receiver that fit jimmy
garoppolo's skill set
and brady kept playing at the level that
he had been playing
um you know over the course of the first
15 years of his career
after the jimmy garoppolo trade tom
brady won three super bowls in five
years
and the patriots wound up having to
trade jimmy garoppolo
so that would be like i mean like to me
it's like it's either a
rogers age is out and you've got jordan
love on the roster to replace him or
b rodgers plays his ass off and now all
of a sudden two years from now you're
you're in a position where maybe you
have to think about trading jordan love
albert brier the senior nfl reporter for
uh the mmqb
i was wondering about the texan
situation with deshaun watson i don't
know what they knew and when they knew
it
because let's say in january they knew
that this was lurking this was on the
horizon or they didn't know
imagine if they had traded him in
january i know and then it came out
now albert that did the texans know
like could you void a deal like i i
don't know i'm just curious about the
timing of all of this and what the
texans knew
and that they didn't you know trade him
at that time
yeah i you know i have a hard time with
it too because i'm not sure what they
knew either and i think it's hard to
have a take on this
because um either a um if you have a
heart if you have a take on it you
either a you're indicting watson which
isn't fair especially considering
you know what sort of citizen he's been
prior to all of this
both as a college player and his pro
player or your b
not taking the allegations seriously
enough and so you know i think we have
to let this play out
i wish i could tell you what the texans
knew in december and january i haven't
gotten any indication that they knew
this was coming
okay um and i i think that the like nick
casario
i mean i could tell you what nick
casario's told teams when they've called
on to sean watson which is basically
you can ask me about any player on the
roster except the quarterback
um so they flat out haven't made them
available
if they had an inkling that there was
trouble coming down the line maybe they
would have i'm not sure
but i do know that this puts everybody
in a really difficult spot because
the texans cannot justify moving on from
a 25 year old franchise quarterback
without getting a historic
haul in return and on the flip side of
it
if you're the broncos or the panthers or
the jets or the dolphins or the niners
at this point can you part with a
historic hall
to get to sean watson without clarity in
this situation i've talked to a couple
teams
that are involved in this dan that have
said flat out no like we
can't do it right now we have to wait
and and because our owner's not gonna
let us do it and we don't
we can't put our jobs on the line that
way so we have to kind of let this thing
play out and get some clarity on the
situation
before we go forward so you never say
never because you know maybe
something happens um and somebody takes
a wild swing it to sean watson thinks
they can get a bargain now and the
texans feel like it's time to move on i
don't know
but i i mean for the most part like the
way i see it and people i've talked to
over the last week about this
i think it effectively is going to
freeze the trade market for deshaun
watson but if the season was starting
he would be on the commissioner's exempt
list i'm guessing yeah
i mean i would think so i would think
but why isn't he
now because he doesn't have to be
because the commitment
because the league okay the league right
now doesn't have to make a big deal out
of this
because there's nothing going on you
know like there's no i mean he
he can't like off-season programs and we
don't know if they're going to start but
the texans off-season program can't
start till a week from monday
so you know i i think the way the league
sort of proceeded in cases like this
more recently you know and there was
that time when
you know it was you know commissioner
you know the commissioner was sort of
like the the hammer
in these sorts of cases i think that
they've taken going back maybe to
antonio brown they've taken like a
little bit more of a rehabilitative
um stance in these things than a
punitive stance
and so i think they've been sort of
careful to punish players when they
don't
necessarily have to um and
i think at this point the league stands
on it probably would be
for right now at least we don't have to
do anything now
if we're going to open up off season
programs on april 5th which is a
possibility
for teams of new coaches the texans fit
into that category maybe at that point
we have to do something and say
something
but i mean like even then we know desean
watson's not going to show up
you know we've already had we've already
established that so
i think the league hasn't done anything
at this point because really they don't
have to do anything
uh i'll leave you with this uh talking
to a sourcing said
there is an outlier who's gonna come up
to the top five
somebody's coming into the top five in
the draft
now if i say that what would be the team
that would be the outlier that you think
might be trying to get into the top five
even
higher i'm told who would that be
okay so like i think everybody knows
caroline is very quarterback
hungry right so they're not now it's not
them yeah it's not them because we know
that they're
i i've been told their owner is quote
unquote obsessed with getting a
quarterback so
uh i'll give you two teams damn um that
i think like
people maybe aren't talking as much
about um
one would be the new england patriots
because they built up their roster to a
point
where uh where i feel like they they
they don't have as many holes you know
like that they have to fill as they had
maybe
two weeks ago and like although bill's
history is to trade down
he has taken opportunities to move up in
the past um
and if you remember in 2012 they traded
up twice to get chandler jones and dante
hightower so when they see something
they think is really special they'll go
and get it
the other team that i think is lurking
out there is the denver broncos
um i think the broncos could get
aggressive with a quarterback
if they see one that they really believe
is a superstar
and so maybe they're the team that jumps
from nine to three
to go get like a justin fields and part
of the reason why they've got a new
general manager and george payton who
isn't tied
to drew locke if you think about it
there are major league questions about
whether or not there's going to be any
first round quarterback prospects in the
2022
draft so if you're a first year gm
you're looking at it right now maybe
you're lukewarm on drew lock
and you say okay if we don't get one
this year and there isn't going to be
one next year
now i could be going into year three as
a general manager still
looking for my guy and so i just keep an
eye on the denver broncos maybe getting
aggressive there within the top ten
by the way i don't have the answer i was
just told that there is an
outlier that you know denver qualifies
an outlier yeah yeah
okay i would think so san francisco
would uh
qualify san francisco's another one yeah
i mean i i think san francisco
i think san francisco is tied to jimmy
until they can find what they feel like
until they can find what they feel like
is a significant upgrade
i've been consistent on that i don't
think they're moving they were never
moving off of jimmy
for they're not moving off of jimmy for
gardner minshew if gardner-menchie is
coming in there
it's as a depth piece because they feel
like they need better depth that
position
um but like i've maintained this all
along like i really feel like if there
was a significant upgrade
they would consider it great to talk to
you again albert thanks for uh
joining us all right thanks dan that's
albert breer the senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
mmqb